This is Jocko podcast number one 36 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Yeah.
Who are these?
Okay.
Why sit they here in twilight,
wherefore rock,
they purgatorial shadows drooping tongues from jaws that slob there relish
bearing teeth that lear like skulls teeth.
Wicked
stroke on stroke of pain.
Yeah,
but what?
Slow panic gouged these chasms rounds there.
Fretted sockets
ever from their hair and threw their hands,
palms,
misery.
Swelters
surely we have perished sleeping and walk in Hell,
but who?
These hellish.
These are men.
Yeah.
Whose minds the dead have ravished
memory fingers in their hair of murders.
Multitudinous murders they once witnessed
waiting slews of flesh.
These helpless wander treading blood from lungs that adds loved laughter
always.
They must see these things and hear them batter of guns and shatter a flying
muscles carnage in comparable and humans squander rocks too thick for these
men's extrication.
Yeah.
Therefore,
still their eyeballs shrink,
tormented back into their brains
because on their sense,
sunlight seems a blood smear.
Knight comes blood black.
Dawn breaks open like a wound that bleeds a fresh,
thus their heads where this hilarious,
hideous,
awful falseness of sets,
smiling corpses.
Thus
their hands are plucking at each other,
picking out rope.
Coutts of their scourging.
Yeah.
Snatching after Ross who smoked them.
Brother
Pauling.
US.
Yeah.
Who dealt them war
and madness.
And that is a poem.
It's a poem called the mental cases
and it's a poem that was written by Wilfred Owen.
He wrote it in 1918 he was a British poet,
but he was also a British soldier
and he was wounded in the first world war.
He was blown up by a trench mortar.
And then he spent several days on unconscious lying with the shredded remains of
one of his fellow officers.
And with those wounds he was also diagnosed,
diagnosed with shell shock.
And he was sent to a place called Craig Lockhart Hospital,
which is where they sent these soldiers to be treated.
And there he recovered to some extent.
Okay.
And then he went back to the front
and dawn,
October 1st in 1918 he led a unit from the second Manchester's as they assaulted
enemy positions in John Court
and he was awarded the military cross for that action.
Okay.
And on the 4th of November,
okay.
Seven days prior,
To November 11th which was the end of the war,
Wilfred Owen was killed in action.
He was shot by a German machine gunner.
And that poem,
okay,
is obviously about the psychological damage that he saw when he was in Craig
Lockhart,
recovering from shell shock.
And I've talked about world war one on this podcast before,
and I've talked about the,
the shell shock.
And if you go to youtube and you Google World War One shell shock and you watch
some of the videos,
you can see the horror of the shell shock,
which reflects the horror of the war itself,
the trenches,
the wounds,
the gas,
the deaf,
the madness of the thousands and thousands and thousands and thousands of deaths
over and over and over again.
And that poem,
mental cases,
it reflects,
okay,
the nightmare of the shell shock inside the nightmare.
Okay.
Well this war
and I
wanted to hear a little bit about what shell shock looked like from the outside.
Did I found an article called Shell shock revisited an examination of the case
records of the National Hospital in London by Stephanie Lind in an Edgar Jones
and they had some good excerpts coming directly from doctors,
nurses that worked in these wards.
And here's one,
this is a case from the case with 27 year old rifleman known as Frank d,
who is diagnosed with functional tremor and neurosis like Dog Korea.
And if you don't know what that is,
it's a disease that gives dogs seizures and tremors and fits.
And if you again go to youtube,
you can see these dogs suffering like that.
And this is what the doctors wrote about.
Frank d patient is a territorial,
which has a reservist who serve heavily in world war one.
Patient is a territorial and went out to France in January.
He has been quite well up to a week ago.
Went on April 26 he was buried under a bomb explosion in the trench.
He was not unconscious but dazed and all in a tremble.
All his limbs were shaking.
He was conscious being carried by his comrades out of the trenches to a dug out.
A few hours afterwards he had to cry and he was crying for two days.
At the same time,
his arms began to twitch very frequently at first,
okay.
He was transferred to the 12th General Hospital and from there to here.
Another case,
another entry about a 23 year old Scottish private known as Henry and Henry m
from the 18th to SARS who is diagnosed with functional facial spasm
on May to May 13th and this is 1915 patient was struck by several pieces of
shrapnel on the right hand,
forearm,
shoulder,
and on the right side of the nose at its base.
He was very dazed,
but did not lose consciousness.
The wounds healed in a month.
About a week after being wounded,
he was operated on and ordered that a piece of shrapnel might be removed from
his face on recovering from the anesthesia.
He found himself unable to move the right side of his face or open his mouth.
This condition,
which is quite painless,
has persisted since and he's not eating solid food or been able to take out his
false teeth.
He has been fed through a rubber tube inserted between his teeth in all other
respects.
He feels well.
Patient sits up in bed gasping in a highly alarming manner with his left face
and a strong tomic spasm and his jaws tightly set.
All efforts to open his mouth are unavailing so strong as the contraction of his
masters.
He declares himself unable to breathe unless sitting up.
And when made the lie down,
his neck is strongly retracted and set and he breathes it violently through his
clenched teeth and holds his breath for as long as he can.
Assuming a purple tinge,
which is apt to be disconcerting until one is a costume to it.
Okay.
By the moral aid given by strong
Farrah Deism,
which is an electric current applied by the physician and force applied to the
jaw,
it is,
it was possible to remove a filthy set of false teeth.
Yeah.
During this performance he uttered piercing shrieks and foamed and is rigidly
held arms shook violently tears,
ran from his eyes and he sweated profusely from his muscular exertion and
resisting the attentions.
Well-Intended though they were of the physician
when asked to close his eyes,
he was able to do
in fact the left eye is half closed and spasm.
All test revealed good power and both sides of the face,
the facial and jaw spasm would seem to be voluntary and due to frank malingering
in the intervals of this grotesque performance.
He lives back on the pillow without any dyspnea,
but he induces an apparent difficulty in breathing.
It will
okay.
Examinations reveal no organic or injury in either nervous or other systems.
Okay,
so just to
recap
there stating that the facial and jaw spasms would seem to be from voluntary and
from malingering.
Basically saying that he's doing this so that he can avoid the war.
Here's another different type of system.
Symptom of shell shock.
This is a 23 year old private named Albert are and it's reported that he had
marked twitching of the face and the whole body at times trembles.
He looks ill and regurgitates wind.
He complains of a peculiar feeling of worms growing in the lower part of the
abdomen.
He coughs considerably and said that his stomach swells up.
A lump appears in his throat,
which chokes him
and he is continually expectorating.
Okay.
The knights are particularly hard on him.
He sits up in bed and has great difficulty breathing,
cannot lie down properly,
but lies over to one side,
either left or right,
puts his hand up
okay
to hold his head still from shaking.
Okay.
He has a depressed and solid look.
There are involuntary movements characterized by a very fine tremor manifested
when his hands are spread out and his fingers are separated.
There's a slight tremor in his legs of the same nature as appears in the other
part of the body.
So those are some examples of this,
this horrible,
the affliction of shell shock.
And as you noticed in some of these,
in that one right up in particular,
there was people that were saying,
oh,
they're just faking this.
They could overcome this if they would.
Okay,
be braver.
Some people did recognize that this was a serious issue and that this was a new
kind of wound in a new kind of war in November of 1914 so this is pretty early
on.
November,
1914 Lord Knutsford,
chairman of the London Hospital House Committee wrote an appeal that was
published in London newspapers and here's what he wrote.
There are certain number of our gallant soldiers for whom no proper provision is
at present,
obtainable,
but is solely needed.
They are suffering from very severe mental and nervous shock due to exposure,
excessive strain and tension.
They can be cured if only they receive proper attention from the physicians who
have made a specialty of treating such conditions.
These men are quite unsuitable patients for general hospitals as their chance of
recovery depends on absolute quiet and on the individual and prolonged attention
of the physician.
If not cured,
these men will drift back to the world as rex and miserable racks for the rest
of their lives.
So there were some people
that recognize this was a,
uh,
a factor that went well beyond the bravery of the individual.
But unfortunately that was probably less percentage of people.
Most most people thought that these individuals that suffered this affliction of
shell shock thought that they were just there.
They were,
they weren't brave.
And you know,
we've,
we've talked about it with a bunch of podcasts.
Dick winters talks about it.
Hackworth talks about it,
that there's a cop that gets filled and if it gets filled too much,
people can't take any more.
And it's not because they're not good people stop because they,
they aren't brave were they weren't brave.
It's,
it's they,
they're done,
they're done.
And there's ways you can treat them.
We've talked about it before.
You see a guy that's looks like he's going to be done.
You need to get him rest.
And if they get rest,
they can recover.
If they don't get rest and they just get continually put into it,
you're going to burn that engine out,
you're going to burn out their brain.
Well,
they didn't quite understand that yet.
And again,
this type of warfare was totally knew there wasn't this kind of just continual
slaughter
ever before.
And if it was,
it was like an incident.
Oh,
there was a huge battle and there was a bunch of people killed.
It wasn't like we're going to go do that again tomorrow.
Well guess what?
These guys are going to go ahead and go and do that same thing tomorrow and the
next day and the next day and the day after that.
So
I want to talk about something that is
as horrible as World War One was.
This might be the most horrible part of World War One.
And I know that's a bold statement,
but I want to start by telling you the story of one individual soldier.
His name was Harry far
and
I'm going to go to a book about his life.
The book is called the,
he was no coward.
It was written by Janet Booth and James White.
And it tells the story of Harry far the Harry far story.
Now it starts off by giving a little background on Harry far and he grew up
young man and it kind of starts off with him meeting who he would eventually
marry a woman by the name of Gertrude and we'll go to the book.
Gertrude and Harry started a walking out together.
They both loved visiting the gaity theater and many a happy evening was spent at
the Hammersmith Empire.
Watching the variety show is the Paris soon became girlfriend and boyfriend and
for the next four years they became inseparable,
but not without some bumps in the roads at the age of 20 Harry was four years
Gertrude's senior,
something her family was not happy about.
But what did she say?
She said,
I love him,
I'm going with him.
And that's that.
So they're young,
they're in love.
And Harry was earning good money working as a scaffolder on the building sites
across London.
And it came as quite a shock in April,
1913 when Gertrude realized she was pregnant,
a child born out of wedlock would bring shame and disgrace on the immediate
family owing to the pending arrival of the baby.
They had to bring their wedding forward and were married as soon as possible.
By the time of the wedding,
they had been together for three years and they were married in Kensington
Registry office in the summer of 1913 a baby who was to be their only child was
born on October 29th of that year.
They named her Gertrude Nelly,
her middle named after Harry Sisterhood emigrated to America.
But the new baby would be known affectionately as little dirty.
Now
prior to meeting,
uh,
dirty Harry had,
well,
I'll go to the book.
Harry had chosen adventures path that in 1908,
so this is previous.
When he had just turned 18 he had decided to join the army.
He enlisted as a regular soldier in the first battalion of the West Yorkshire
regimen known as the Prince of Wales.
Home.
Little is known of his two years as a regular soldier,
but later records records show he was considered to be a reliable and
trustworthy soldier with an exemplary record of good behavior.
Now this happens in America as well when you're on active duty,
which is what he was those first two years.
When you get done with active duty,
they put you on some sort of reserve status.
There's,
I think it's called IRR and maybe it stands for immediate regular reserve.
I don't really remember.
I was on it for some amount of time but I don't remember and it's basically when
you're out,
but they can recall you and then you can say active reserve,
which is when you're still getting paid.
Maybe you should do some drills and what not.
It sounds like he was in a combinate when he got out.
He was in a combination of those two will go to the book.
Most soldiers who had left the army were automatically placed in the section be
reserved.
It meant that for five years they could be called upon in the event of general
mobilization and were paid three shillings and six pence per week as a retainer
while also being obliged to undertake periodic training.
So that's sorta like the reserves.
I had to throw this in there.
And a pamphlet entitled a Short History of the West Yorkshire Regiment,
the excitable introduction to the unit nicknamed the old and bold claims.
No regimen in the British army has a more glorious history than the West
Yorkshire Regiment.
The Prince of Wales Zone.
Yeah,
for its record and gallon and
devoted service to king and country in many parts of the empire is equaled by
few and surpassed by none.
So proud history
and
can probably figure out where this is going.
The war kicks off.
World War One kicks off and he gets recalled to go and serve back to the book.
He had previously served with the regimens first battalion,
but its soldiers were already in France when he returned to duty.
So he joined the second battalion before his passions to France.
Harry was granted a weekend passed,
allowing him to return to London and spend a precious last few days with his
wife and young child dirties.
First Birthday was celebrated that weekend and Gertrude promise to write her
husband frequently as well as sending him food and clothing parcels after what
must have been an extremely difficult for a well.
Harry returned to camp having slightly overstate as pass,
subsequently being forced to forfeit four days pay
like Harry,
the majority of his fellow comrades had never boarded a boat before,
let alone left England shores despite reasonably smooth crossing to France,
many of the men suffer from seasickness.
Those not being sick.
We're in good cheer and eager to face the enemy in battle.
The general consensus of the men being that by Christmas this bloody war will be
over
so that doesn't,
it turns around pretty quick.
Even in the book.
That part turns around quick,
pretty quick and obviously I skip some sections,
but we get right into it.
On November 13th at 11:00 PM the West Yorkshire is to relieve the Devin regimen.
The very next day,
the soldiers came under fire for the first time and suffered their first
casualties with three men wounded.
Okay?
Indeed.
One account of the battalions.
First taste of trench warfare.
Describe the soldiers great discomfort in heavy mud
at times.
During this period,
the trenches occupied by the West Yorkshire Regiment.
Soldiers were two to six feet deep in water and cold mud baths were common,
so also was the inevitable accompaniment of sickness.
On November 19th for the battalion lost its first man to sniper fire with
another six wounded.
Even when the men were resting in the barns and houses allocated behind to to
them behind the lines,
there was no response from the shelling
acting sergeant Walter Western record the difficulty of fighting in the rapidly
deteriorating conditions.
He wrote the continual rain where the whole terrain had turned into a quagmire
of liquid mud,
making it difficult for the transport,
carrying supplies and weapons to continue along the muddy roads.
Every so often they had to stop and push the vehicles over.
The cloying mud,
even more harrowing was to try to pull comrades out of the mud.
Many perished by slipping off the duck boards and disappearing into the slime.
The day spent in wet and muddy trenches,
left some soldiers incapacitated by trends foot and invariably resulted in many
of the men having a foot or both feet amputated.
Pitiful sight of the horses and mules stuck in the rain.
Sodden soil struggling to free themselves from the mud.
So yeah,
we think about trench foot and you know,
think,
oh your feet are uncomfortable or whatever.
You don't think about having one or both of your feet amputated.
Hmm.
December 18th the West Yorkshire regiments kernel and captains were told that
the second battalion Devin regimen would be attacking the German trench and two
companies of Yorkshire men would be sent in support to dig and make good any
captured trenches.
The official battalion diary records,
the Devin attack commence from the left and was late and starting the right
company,
never advanced,
thus creating a block in the trenches.
The left companies attack was unsuccessful owing to the wire arrangements,
but the left center,
a company occupied 150 yards of the main German trench.
I've midnight the entire second battalion of the West Yorkshire Regiment was
ordered to take over the captured trench and improve it for defense while their
comrades dug in alongside.
However,
at 8:00 AM the Germans responded with hand grenades thrown in great quantities
and very rapidly forcing the men occupying the trench to retreat to the British
front line.
As a consequence of the sudden action,
the company of West Yorkshire soldiers attempting to dig on the right were left
exposed and suffered withering on filleted fire.
They also retreated an end.
The attack ended in failure and the battalion suffered.
Two officers killed,
two wounded and 120 other ranks,
killed or wounded,
almost all sustained in the retreat
the new year.
And again,
um,
advancing through the book and to get the full details,
get the book and read it.
The New Year of 1915 began as the old one finished for the Yorkshire Man,
cold,
wet,
and in the trenches.
January six,
one man was killed and a lieutenant was taken to the hospital
despite the hostile nature of the enemy,
just a few hundred yards in front of them.
The battalion nine diary noted that the main cause of casualties was
increasingly a result of sickness
as well as the of the ever present water and mud disease and sickness was
carried by living sources from the lice that infested every bit of clothing to
the rats that feasted on the unbury dead.
Paul Fussell writes,
the stench of rotten flesh was over.
Everything hardly replaced by hardly repressed by the chloride of lime sprinkled
on particularly offensive sites,
dead horses and dead men and parts of both where sometimes not buried for months
and often simply became an element of parapets and trench walls.
You could smell the line miles before you could see it.
So if you've ever smelled a dead body before,
it's,
it's an absolutely horrible,
horrible,
horrible smell.
Yeah,
and when you think about the places where you're living are actually partially
built from bodies and parts of bodies,
it's hard to even imagine what the stench was and how bad it was.
Back to the book.
One man was killed and another wounded on January 12th on January 19th the
trenches,
it dried out slightly and four men were injured in action.
On January 25th rifle,
fire was recorded as being heavier than usual,
but ultimately the expected attack never came though three men were killed in
the course of the day.
The following day was off to the billets in La Flint Gay.
This time in the brigade reserve,
two men were killed in one wounded,
but a draft of 50 men arrived.
Yeah.
On the last day of the month,
snow fell with water building in the trenches,
but the enemy was quiet.
The whole month of January had been spent either in the trenches or in the
nearby reserve with no time spent any distance away from the guns.
Okay.
On February 4th the battalion relieved second battalion,
four men were killed and five are wounded.
On February 10th the battalion was back in the line losing one man and two
wounded on February 11th
okay.
March 6th five men were injured some severely.
When they hit,
they were hit by shrapnel in the morning.
Two of the five died of their wounds later that day.
It's weird you think about this.
It's just pecking away.
It's just pecking away day after day after day after day.
Yeah,
you got,
you got 250 guys or something in your company,
maybe 200 guys in your company and it's too here.
It's three there.
It's eight wounded there.
It's full wounded there and then you get,
you get drafts come in,
which is new,
fresh 50 of them coming in to replace the guys that you've lost.
Officers were issued with a full set of orders on March 9th for the attack on
new VA Chapelle
March 10th at 7:30 AM the bombardment of enemy positions began with wire
cutting,
shrapnel to aid any breakthroughs by the infantry.
The first shell to fall was fired by an impressive 15 inch howitzer and wait and
incredible 1400 pounds.
However,
their advance was blocked.
The battalion then withdrew back to British trenches and held the line.
Casualties had been severe as they had crossed,
as they had across the front.
On the murderous first day of the battle,
23 members of the battalion were dead.
51 men had been wounded.
Three we're missing,
but the savage fighting was to continue.
At 4:00 AM the next day orders received to move.
17 members of the regiment were killed outright.
40 men and one officer were wounded.
Format,
we're missing shelling continued inflicting heavy casualties on the severely
depleted West Yorkshire men as they huddled in the trenches in cold and misty
conditions.
Okay.
By this stage of the attack,
the infantry soldiers were exhausted.
Dead on their feet,
would have been an accurate description.
The condition of the gallon fellows who had been fighting and marching to and
from the trenches since the early hours of the 10th with practically no respites
was now pitiable.
Okay.
Men fell asleep at every Holt having to be roused by violent means
among the ranks.
14 men were killed.
31 wounded six when is missing?
Okay.
At 7:00 PM the soldiers moved off the unoccupied a line of trenches.
Grimly the battalion diarists noted.
We found this trench unoccupied.
Okay.
And full of dead.
Yeah.
The deaths and injuries continued forward.
Killed 28 wounded three went missing during the day.
November 5th
General Haig who was to become the commander in chief of the British
expeditionary force the following year wrote in his diary
that why my one fought was how soon I could get my battle worn troops relieved
and give it a few days rest out of the trenches and shell fire.
Yeah.
On July 30th,
1915 he was even more explicit saying one lesson of this war was that troops
could stand up for days,
hard fighting and then must be relieved.
So you take that right there,
you take four days,
but that that's an average from this guy that's seen these folks on the front
line does.
That means there's people that are less than that.
There's some people that are more,
some people can handle eight days,
10 days.
Some people can handle one day,
but some people can't handle any.
The average is four days and here are these guys on the line for 10 20 1317 days
at a time and there is times that I'm not mentioning where there they're going
back off the front line and they're getting a little bit of recovery,
but then they're going right back in and it's not four days if they're going
into before they're going in for eight days for 12 days.
Back to the book,
there was a little action with two men killed in one wounded.
The battalion was relieved by the Second Battalion Lincoln Regiment and marched
to bill.
It's just a mile away from the battleground.
The second battalion had lost more than a quarter of its strength.
Marching teeth dawned cold and wet and despite the battalion diarists noting
that it was quiet.
Okay,
three men were killed.
Quiet day three men were killed.
April 6th the shell exploded in a company,
bill it killing three and injuring eight
5:00 AM on May 9th the artillery bombardment of the enemy trenches began with
the attack launched just 40 minutes later.
So here we are on another attack on another attack during the shelling and small
arms fire from the Germans.
There were three were killed,
13 were wounded and three posted is missing.
And this results in the French attack on vme ridge failed after a week costing
the French a hundred thousand casualties.
Okay.
The British attack on Aubers Ridge,
which is what they were working on,
failed ignominiously.
So that's the life,
if you can call it that.
And here's where we start to hear a little bit about Harry.
By this time,
Harry had been withdrawn from the front line suffering from what was becoming
known as shell shock.
He was taken off duty on May 9th
however,
rather than being viewed as a psychological condition,
some doctors and researchers were viewing the symptoms more in line with a
neurological disorder or the result of a concussion from shell blast treatment
for the condition.
Largely involved rest away from the front line and possibly some talking
therapies that we would now refer to as counseling.
Some doctors utilize the electric shock therapy in isolation therapy on
softwares,
but both were unproven and experimental.
Yeah.
And there's a Dr. Stevenson that says post stress disorder,
this is looking back,
post traumatic stress disorder was exacerbated by the special conditions of
static warfare in which soldiers endured repeated bombardments in confined
spaces with little control over their fate
and live day by day in close proximity to their comrades.
Decomposing remains.
So I've talked about this before.
We talked about it when Jordan was on with Jordan Peterson.
When you don't have any control,
when you're not on offense it,
it's a lot harder to deal with psychologically and this is the ultimate
defensive.
You're just going to get bombed and there's nothing you can do about it.
And by the way,
you're going to watch your friends and your comrades get wounded and killed
every single day.
Back to the book,
in the summer of 1915 Gertrude received a letter from France,
but she did not recognize the handwriting on the envelope as Harris.
So his wife gets a letter,
she has recognize the handwriting.
The letter stated that Harry was ill and in the hospital he had been evacuated
from the hoop lanes area in May as he had been suffering from what was known as
shell shock stricken by nervous exhaustion.
His hands had been shaking too much to hold a pencil,
so a nurse at the hospital had written the letter for him.
Again,
uncontrollable shaking is what these guys are experiencing so bad he can't write
his letter.
A letter to his wife after the extended period behind the lines,
Harry was assessed and certified fit.
He was sent back to the West Yorkshire Regimen this time joining the first
battalion part of the 18th Infantry Brigade sixth division in October of 1915
October 21st 89 men including Harry,
joined the battalion while it was camped behind the line.
Shortly after the Germans launched a huge barrage against allied rest areas
along all the front end retaliate in retaliation for royal artillery shelling of
their own billets.
Although little damage was done,
the sound of the guns which had caused Harry to fall ill before had begun all
over again for him.
Okay.
At the end of the month of Italian,
began an 11 day spell in the trenches characterized by heavy rain collapsing
fortifications and mud.
By November 3rd and officer had been killed and almost all dug outs had
collapsed,
leaving men with little respect from the appalling weather
on December 5th the battalion march to Everling spending the next 10 days
forming working parties to carry out tasks such as repairing paths despite not
being in the line.
Casualties were sustained when the parties were shelled and fired upon.
By rifleman.
Though even when you go back to the rear,
you're still getting shot and killed.
December 19th when the area came under antillary bombardment and that
frightening phenomenon of battle,
the use of gas,
the action began at 5:30 AM when the British held trenches came under heavy
rifle fire than at 6:45 AM when troops were stood.
Two in anticipation for an attack.
Shell's containing gas were fired by the Germans.
The effect,
the gas was instantaneous and horrifying during the day.
11 men died in 23 were wounded to suffering the effects of gas.
Total allied losses on the day as a direct result of gas were 1069 casualties
and 69 deaths.
The battalion was back in the trenches for the end of the year and the start of
the new one on December 30th
okay.
The battalion headquarters were shelled suffering.
Two men killed and four injured.
On February 14th German artillery shells fell again in the battalion killing
five and injuring 15 by the time the first battalion left the trenches the next
evening,
it had suffered the losses of nine killed and 51 injured.
It underscores the losses suffered by the British army during the first World
War when 7,000 soldiers were killed and wounded every day.
As a matter of course.
Okay,
7,000 a day.
March 17th as they marched the four miles to begin a period of rest,
that was the last a month two men were killed and three men were wounded.
How the soldiers were afflicted as not recorded.
It's first spell back in the trenches of that.
Go get some rest.
Now it's coming back at a first bell back in the trenches after a month away
from the line.
Five were wounded in five killed
during April.
Harry reported sick with nerves and was treated at addressing station for two
weeks before returning to frontline duty.
His problems were worsening,
yet the fact
he was not sent far behind the lines suggest medical officers did not deem him
sick enough to be evacuated.
June 3rd
nother operation losses during the operation.
We're heavy with one officer in five sergeants killed as well as five other
ranks.
Two Sergeants in 24 other ranks were wounded,
a total casualty rate of about 17%
on July 1st less than a hundred miles south of position.
Following a week in which 1.6 million shells were fired.
British forces attacked on Mass on a 15 mile long front.
The slaughter that ensued on the first day of the battle of the Somme was
prodigious
with almost 60,000 British casualties.
A third of them dead
news of the slaughter took days to filter back to Britain and thanks to heavy
censorship of the press,
the horrors of the battle.
We're not truly expressed,
but the casualty lists gave no lie to the situation.
Yeah.
On July 15th the West Yorkshire's left camp and moved by train to eat braze
where they relieve the 11th battalion.
Harry again reported sick with nerves on July 22nd and was detained by Medical
Corp soldiers for the day.
But this time he was returned as fit for duty the next day.
So this guy's fallen apart.
He keeps asking for help and they keep sending him back to the front.
And mind you,
he's an estate.
I mean,
not all the time,
but he's at least reaching a state where he can't even write a letter to his
wife,
can't even steady as hand for that,
and they're putting him back to the front.
Over and over again.
On August 6th camp was broken and the battalion march the battalion have joined
the battle of the Somme,
infamous for the unprecedented British losses and intensity of the shelling
operation.
The next four days were spent in the brigade reserve as before with hundreds of
men sent digging and caring duties.
This work proved more hazardous than the previous week with four killed,
nine wounded,
one man missing believed to have blown up.
On September 11th the battalion proceeded with brigade to an area known as sand
pits.
The following day was spent with the brigade in reserve.
In
six men were killed and four more wounded Amman.
Amid a general British offensive across the sector involving the use of the
latest weapon tanks.
On September 18th the battalion joined other forces of six division in attacking
opposing trenches.
At 5:50 AM whistle sounded along the line,
his soldiers poured up over the front trenches through previously cut barbed
wire and petite and between breast works.
Companies were met with very heavy machine gun and rifle fire and more.
First forced to retreat back from the trenches where the attack started from.
Okay.
The cost was shockingly high with more than a hundred casualties across the
battalion and attrition rate of more than 10% among the 13 dead were three
officers,
almost a hundred officers,
almost a hundred soldiers were wounded,
including four officers.
Later on September 19th the exhausted soldiers made their way to bill.
It's eight miles away where they remained overnight and the following day
the attack was considered a success,
but private far had not taken part in the operation is final nervous collapse
took place on September 17th Harry had fallen out sick on September 16th yet
when he made his way to addressing station the following day,
he was not seeing because he was not wounded.
On September 17th he was ordered to the front in the company of a rations party,
but was founded 11:00 PM that night at the same place behind the lines having
disobeyed the order
when he was subsequently sent to the front under escort,
he struggled with his guards and was released after refusing to see a medical
officer further to forward here,
we ran back towards the transport lines and the rear end was held under guard
before being placed under arrest on September 18th and charged with cowardice.
The timing of his collapse ahead of the impending attack may have helped along
the decision to charge him.
The Battle of the Somme resulted in the greatest loss of life in military
history at the time for negligible gains
across the whole offensive.
During that awful summer and autumn,
between July 1st and November 19th British army suffered 420,000 casualties.
The French 195,000 and the German losses stood between 500 and 650,000
okay.
So the massive fighting that was going on at the battle of Somme is also
reflected in the fact that they're being super hostile towards him.
October 2nd,
1916 private Harry far stood trial by field general court martial,
which was convened
at Hill Serrano in France.
Since his nervous collapse and arrest his battalion had again been an action
following their part in the success in the capture of the quadrilateral.
This time they'd helped attack and take the village of live buffs.
On September 25th part of the wider battle of more vol,
it was against this backdrop of missing two significant actions that Harry was
tried
a field general court martial was a wartime disciplinary tribunal with the power
to try all military offenses.
So obviously,
you know,
these guys are are,
they're not looking to hear about your excuses of why you can't get after it
with the rest of the troops and the rest of the troops are going forward.
The rest of the,
I mean,
the rest of the troops are going forward and they're fighting and they're
fighting hard and they're making incredible sacrifices.
Something that he wasn't physically able to do at this point.
He was,
he lost it.
He had seen too much.
He had done too much and he was done.
So they're sending him to court.
Marshal Harry was charged with an offense contrary to section four seven of the
army act of 1881 the exact charge wasn't misbehaving before the enemy in such a
manner as to show cowardice,
to which he pleaded not guilty.
He Harry appeared without a prisoner's friend.
So there was,
there wasn't no,
there was no like lawyer to defend him.
It was just him,
just him
assessing the overall situation.
Captain Whitlow said,
I cannot say what has destroyed this man's nerves,
but he has proved himself on many occasions incapable of keeping his head
inaction.
And likely to cause a panic.
However,
the officer made a point of differentiating between these problems and the
unfortunate soldiers nature saying apart from his behavior,
his conduct and character are very good.
So he's got one person that comes forward and says,
Hey,
he's not a bad guy.
He's just,
he's just lost it right now.
Okay.
Because he did a fair amount of fighting.
The next piece of evidence was signed by Wwe William the battalion's medical
officer.
He wrote,
I hereby certify that I examined Private Harry Far First Battalion York's on
October 2nd,
1916 and that in my opinion,
both the general physical and mental condition or satisfactory.
Interestingly,
the word good appears before the word satisfactory,
but it's struck out by the same hand indicating some doubts in the officer's
mind.
The trial began formally with a prosecution witness,
regimental sergeant,
sergeant major h laking,
who said on 17 September,
1916 about 9:00 AM the accused reported himself to me at a line transport.
He states that he was sick and had fallen out from the company the night
previous on the march up to the trenches.
He states he could not find his company commander for permission to fall out.
I order him to report to the dressing station when he returns.
He states that he,
they would not see him as he was not wounded.
I then ordered him to proceed to the battalion with the ration party,
which was going in the evening.
The ration party paraded about 8:00 PM the accused was present and marched off
with it.
On the arrival at the ration dump company,
Quartermaster Sergeant Booth reported to me that the accused was missing on
returning to the first line for about 11:00 PM I saw the accused standing near a
brazier.
I asked him why he there?
He replies,
I cannot stand it.
I asked him what he meant.
He again replies,
I cannot stand it.
I told him he would have to go to the trenches that night.
He replies,
I cannot go.
I order
company Quartermaster Sergeant Booth to take him up to the trenches under
escort.
After going 500 yards to the accused commences to scream and struggle with his
I again warned him that he would have to go to the trenches or be tried for
cowardice.
He replied,
I am not fit to go to the trenches.
I then said I would take him to see a medical officer.
He refused to go saying,
I will not go any further.
That way.
I ordered the escort to take him on.
The accused,
started against struggling and screaming,
so they were actually wanting to take him to a medical officer.
That's further forward and he's not going.
He's done.
The second witness to be called was company Quartermaster Sergeant Jw booth of
the First Battalion West Yorkshire Regimen and he says on September 17th,
1916 about 3:00 PM I ordered the accused to parade with the caring party at 6:00
PM to go up to join his company in the trenches.
The accused paraded and marched off with the rash and party on arrival at the
ration dump.
The accused was absent,
having fallen out on the way without permission.
About 9:00 PM I saw the accused near the first line transport.
The regimental sergeant major ordered me to take the accused with the escort to
the trenches about 500 yards from the first line transport.
The accused became violent,
threatened the escort and eventually broke away returning to the first line
transport.
The regimental sergeant major ordered me to place the accused in charge of a
guard.
Yeah,
those stories kind of line up.
The third witness was private d Ferrar who also appears to have survived the
war.
He said on September 17th,
1916 about 11:30 PM I was ordered by company quartermaster sergeant booth to
form part of an escort to take the accused up to his company in the trenches.
After going about 500 yards,
the accused started struggling and saying he wanted to see a doctor.
The sergeant major said he would see one when he got a bit further up the
accused refuse to go any further.
I tried to pull them along.
The sergeant major told me to let him go and the accused went back to the first
line transport.
So there's the perspective of the folks that were with
private far and here is private fars defense.
This is what he had to say about the situation
on 16th September,
1916 when going up to the trenches with my company,
I fell out sick.
I could not find the company officer to obtain permission to sergeant.
I asked has now been or went back to the first line transport arriving there
about 2:00 AM on 17 September,
1916 I would've reported at once the regimental sergeant major only I was told
he was asleep.
I reported about 9:00 AM on 17 September.
The sergeant major told me to go to the advanced dressing station.
They however,
would not see me as I was not wounded.
The sergeant major told me to go up with the rash and party at night.
I started with this party and had to fall out sick.
Yeah,
I could not get permission.
As I was in the rear and the sergeant major was in the front,
but left word with a private soldier,
I returned to the first line transport,
hoping to report sick to some medical officer there
on the sergeant major's return.
I reported to him and said I was sick and I could not stand it.
Okay.
He then said,
you are a fucking coward and you will go to the trenches.
I give fuck all for my life and I give fuck all for yours and you'll get fucking
well shot.
The sergeant major company,
quartermaster booth and private Farrar then took me toward the trenches.
We went about a mile when we met a caring party returning from returning under
lance corporal form.
The sergeant major asked Lance corporal form where I was and he replied,
runaway,
same as last night.
I said to sergeant major,
you have got this all made up for me.
Okay.
The sergeant major then told Lance corporal form to fall out to men and take me
to the trenches.
They commenced to shoved me.
I told them not to as I was sick enough as it was the sergeant major.
Then grab my rifle and said,
I'll blow your fucking brains out if you don't go.
I then called out for an officer,
but there was none.
Yeah.
I was then tripped up and commence to struggle after this.
I do not know what happened until I found myself back in the first line
transport under a guard.
If the escort had not started to shove me about,
I would have gone up to the trenches.
Okay.
It was on account of their doing this that I commenced to struggle
after the statement.
Harriers Cross examined by the courts prosecutor who asked if he had had the
opportunity of reporting six since September 16th here we replied yes.
After it was put her under arrest on 18 September.
Yeah.
A member of the court marshal then asked why he had not reported sick since his
first arrest,
to which he replied fatefully
because being away from the shell fire,
I felt better.
Yeah.
Evidence too as to the character private far was presented to the court.
The battalion's adjutant,
lieutenant w Paul stated that he knew Harry for six weeks.
He said on working parties,
he has three times asked for leave to fall out and return to camp as he could
not stand the noise of our,
the artillery.
He was trembling and did not appear to be in a fit state.
So Harry had spent four years in the service of his country two years before the
war and two years during it.
The private soldier took part in a number of actions with his infantry
battalion.
Most notably the battle of [inaudible] Chapelle.
It was one of the most intense and attritional chapters of the entire conflict
on the western front.
One of the first examples of the wholesale slaughter of British troops for which
the first world war has become renowned.
Within months he was in the hospital.
His nerves shattered with a diagnosis of shell shock.
Yet he returned to the front in October of 1915 and fought on for another 11
months with two more spells of sickness because of his shell shock.
According to Chris Walsh in the cowardice of brief history as a world war,
one dragged on,
Captain Charles Wilson of the Royal Army Medical Corps observed fear was no
longer an occasional and exotic visual visitor,
but a settler in our midst.
It's cumulative effect led Wilson later Lord Moran,
which was Sir Winston Churchill's personal doctor to think that a man's ability
to hold up against it,
his courage was not absolute quality of his character,
but something he had a certain amount of like money in a bank account and which
could be depleted slowly or suddenly by the hardships and horrors of war.
Harry far had reached the limit of his endurance and could go no further.
Okay.
And so the trial was over.
There was no lawyer,
those soldiers,
friend,
no support,
and there was no mercy back to the book.
The wording on the charge sheet was starting
okay.
Under a column entitled finding.
And if convicted sentence,
two words were handwritten in Pencil.
Okay.
Guilty.
Yes,
there was no right to an appeal.
And late 1916 a telegram arrived for Gertrude,
far from the war office,
opening the envelope with trembling hands and a fucking heart.
She read the bold type written message that realized her worst fears.
Okay.
Harry far had died in France,
but not in battle or of wound sustained under fire.
Rereading it in disbelief.
Gertrude learned that her husband
had been executed by firing squad.
The stark message read we,
we get,
we regret to inform you.
Okay.
That Harry Thomas,
far of the first West Yorkshire Regimen has been shot for showing cowardice in
the face of the enemy.
Okay.
Shot for showing cowardice in the face of the enemy.
And unfortunately he was not the only one.
There were 351 men executed by the British army during World War One and more
than 300 of those,
just over 300 of those were for there.
Suppose it to cowardice.
Okay.
And there is a book called a shot at dawn.
Bye Julien.
Put Koski and Julian Sykes
and it's called shot at dawn because that was generally when these executions
were carried out.
They were carried out in the,
in the early morning.
And it details some of those men that actually details all the men and their
deaths and
okay.
Provide some insight from some of the people that were there during these
horrible times.
So I'm going to go to that book.
The first sentence of death imposed on a soldier.
Of the B e f which is the British expeditionary forces,
was carried out in the fifth week of the war and the condemned soldier was
private,
Thomas Highgate from Kent.
He had been born in the little village of Shoreham nearest Sevenoaks seven oaks
and I joined the army in February,
1913 like many who enlisted for regular army service.
The latter joined up
at the age of 17
after less than two weeks in action,
the private have deserted on the day that he went missing.
His battalion had started to move northwards advancing Highgate who's wearing
civilian clothing was discovered by a game keeper hiding in a barn.
His uniform,
his concealed nearby.
When questioned,
he said,
I want to get out of it and this is how I'm going to do it.
Not surprisingly private Highgate and was found guilty.
The sentences imposed was that he would suffer death by being shot.
17 year old kid
in March,
1915 to soldiers from one West Yorkshire Regiment were convicted of desertion
and then were shot within a few days of each other.
The first Lance Corporal Alfred Atkinson deserted whilst in rest,
the battalion being under orders to proceed to the front.
In January of that year,
Atkinson had want us some of money gambling and after about of drinking,
subsequently deserted after three weeks,
he was then arrested by the military police.
At his trial,
the court was told that Atkinson was a good soldier and previously have
excellent character.
As a result,
his sentence bore a recommendation to mercy.
A soldier serving with the battalion at the time later confirmed his opinion
saying that Atkinson was clean,
smart,
brave soldier represented by all are respected by all his comrades.
When General Sir Horace Smith Dorian reviewed the proceedings.
He was of the opinion that an example was required and the sentence was
confirmed
and here's an eye witness of an account.
The two men,
and this is labor and Pete Ernst.
Third will the two men I selected for the firing party went with the adjutant.
When they came back,
tough characters though,
they were supposed to be,
they were sick.
Okay.
They screamed in their sleep,
they vomited immediately after eating.
All they could say was the site was horrible,
made more so by the fact that we had shot one of our own men,
private Abraham.
Bev Verstein
was the only son of an east end family because it was considered dishonorable in
certain Jewish circles to be a soldier.
Bev Verstein had signed up under the false name of Harris 1915 Christmas Eve
private.
Bev Verstein was a wounded in the back he had,
he was admitted to the hospital suffering from these wounds and also from shock
in his letters home private.
Bev Verstein told of his progress in the hospital and that he had been detained
there since 19 January,
1916 because he had developed a pressure sore on his heel first January,
1916 dear mother,
I'm very sorry that I did not write before now,
but we were in the trenches on Christmas Day and we had a lot to do.
Also,
I was taken ill and was sent to the hospital.
I am feeling a little better,
so don't get upset.
Also,
don't send any letters to the company because I won't get them all.
So you cannot send any letters to the hospital as I won't get them.
Dear mother,
do not worry.
I will be all right hoping all of you are getting on.
Well,
I was only hurt in the back.
I will try to send you letters every few days if I can to let you know how I am
getting on.
We get plenty of food in the hospital.
Dear mother,
I know it will break your heart this,
but don't be upset about it.
I will be all right,
but I would very much like to see you.
I will try my very best
and he did recover
and
he went back to the front.
On 13 February,
the soldier had left his position in the front line trenches and made his way to
one of the company headquarters in the rear.
He reported to his company,
Quartermaster Sargent and stated that a grenade had burst very close to him and
that he was suffering from shock believing him to be a nervous condition.
This NCO told Harris to report the medical officer.
Bev [inaudible] reported to the medical officer who examined him but found
nothing wrong.
As a result,
the private was ordered to return to the trenches.
Beverage scene,
however,
did not obey,
but made his way to a farmhouse in the rear where he took refuge.
Shortly thereafter,
waltzed warming himself by a fire.
An officer from another regimen came into the farm house and suspecting that
beverage [inaudible] was deserted,
replaced the lad under arrest.
The letter sent home indicated that beverage scene wasn't trouble but did not
disclose the serious nature of his predicament.
Clearly as a soldier did not realize that his life was at stake.
But the letters relate that at the time of his desertion,
the private had been feeling unwell.
23 February,
1916 dear mother,
we were in the trenches and I was ill,
so I went out and they took me to prison and I am a bit of trouble now and I
won't get any money for a long time.
I will have to go to the front,
go in front of a court.
I will try my best to get out of it,
so don't worry.
But dear mother tried to send some money,
not very much,
but try your best.
I will let you know in my next how I got on,
give my best love to mother,
father and Kate,
your loving son
Abby.
On March 4th when he was court marshaled private beverage,
Dean explained that on the day of his absence a grenade had exploded beside him
and this had been more than his nerves could stand.
He added that he had done lost control.
The court was unimpressed by this story and in spite of an unblemished record,
the soldier was sentenced to death and the finding was confirmed by the
commander in chief private beverage teens.
Parents were left unaware of their sons predicament.
The next communication which they received came from the army.
It was an official army form which carried a blunt message.
Yeah
Sir.
I'm directed to inform you that a report has been received from the war office
to the effect that private Harris,
a 11th Battalion Middlesex Regiment G S was signed with sentence after trial by
court marshal to suffer death by being shot for desertion and the sentence was
duly executed on 20 March,
another one,
and again this book is,
is details every single soldier and I'm picking out some of the,
some of the ones that stood out a bit to me.
The next soldier concern was rifle been Albert Parker serving with seven kings
royal rifle core.
His crime was typical example of desertion committed with the intention of
avoiding service in the line.
35 year old Parker admitted drunkenness at his trial,
but this did not mitigate his offense and I witness later recalled the
promulgation of sentence and the execution that followed.
Then the prisoners cap was taken off
and he was told to take one pace forward,
which he did the a p m commence to read the papers.
The man was then told to take a pace back again,
which he did without a quiver.
Okay.
A braver man at that moment.
It wasn't to be found in France.
He was then marched away to the place where he was to be shot.
We were then ordered to about turn and the brigade transport officer threatened
us that any man who turned around would be put on a crime.
Okay,
so we stood in silence for what seemed hours,
although only minutes.
Then the shots rang out and one of the Yorkshire's fainted.
The strain was that great.
Still we stood in silence until we heard another shot,
which I afterwards ascertained was the doctor shot to make sure he was dead.
Private.
Phillips of one Coldstream guards was executed for desertion.
The clergymen who attended private Philips was captain t Guy Rodgers chaplain to
the second guards.
A brigade.
The core Jamon documented his feelings and what he clearly regarded as a most
whoring or deal 31 May,
1916 shall I tell you over the terrible experience I've just gone through.
If so,
it must not go beyond the family circle of yourself and the hows Lems it has
just fallen to my lot to prepare a dessert before his death.
That breaking the news to him,
helping him with his last letters,
passing the night with him on the straw in his cell and trying to prepare his
soul for meeting God.
Okay.
The execution and burying him immediately.
The shadow was just hanging over me when I wrote the last letter,
but I tried to keep it out Monday night I was with him Tuesday morning at three
30 he was shot.
He laid beside me for hours with his hand in mind.
Poor fellow.
It was a bad case,
but he met his end bravely and drinking all I could teach them about God,
his father.
Jesus is savior and the reality of the forgiveness of sins.
Yeah.
I feel shaken by it all,
but my nerves,
thank God,
have not troubled me.
Everyone has been so kind who knew of the ordeal.
I will tell you some more some other time.
I want to get it off and away from the thought of it as much as I can.
Here's a few guys that deserted together in a group,
Lance,
Sergeant Joseph Stones,
Lance Corporal Peter Goggins and Lance Corporal John MacDonald.
In the new year when Sir Douglas Haig came to review the sentences,
he commuted the those imposed on the four private.
So there's a for privates with these guys.
These guys were the leaders of this group that deserted,
which were suspended,
but an eye witness account recorded the final moments of the three condemned and
CEO's shot on 18 January.
Come out.
You ordered the corporal of the guard to me.
I crawled fourth.
It was snowing heavily.
Stand here.
He said,
pushing me between two centuries.
Quick March.
Okay,
and away we went.
Not as I dreaded to my first taste of pack drill,
but out and up along the Long Street to an r e dump
there the police corporal handed in the chip where upon three posts,
three rows ropes and a spade were given to me to carry back our return journey
took us past the guard room up a short hail until we reached a secluded spot
surrounded by trees.
Certain measurements were made in the snow after which I was ordered to dig
three holes as stipulated distances apart.
I began to wonder,
could it be,
yeah,
no,
perhaps spies perhaps.
Oh,
perhaps only my fancy.
Okay.
The next scene of piercingly called dawn.
A crowd of brass hats,
the medical officer and three firing parties,
three steaks,
a few yards apart,
and a ring of centuries around the woodland to keep the curious away,
a motor ambulance arrives conveying the doomed men manacled and blindfolded.
They are helped out and tied to the stakes
over each man's heart is placed in an envelope.
At the sign of command,
the firing parties 12 each align their rifles on the envelopes.
The officer in charge holds his stick,
a loft.
It has,
it falls.
36 bullets usher the souls of three of Kitchener's men to the great unknown.
Yeah.
As a military prisoner,
I helped clear the traces of the triple murder.
Okay.
I took the post down.
I helped carry those bodies toward their last resting place.
I collected all the blood soaked Strawn,
burnt it,
acting upon instructions.
I took their belongings from the dead.
Men's tunics discarded before being shot.
A few letters,
a pipe,
some fags,
a photo.
I could tell you of the silence of the military police.
After reading one letter from a little girl too.
Dear Daddy,
another [inaudible]
private,
David Stevenson on sensing danger,
the soldier had run off when questioned the private that lied,
saying that he was working for another town mayor on.
Unfortunately for Stevenson,
he was already under suspected suspended sentence for previous offense of
desertion,
the recollections of an x sergeant who had been in charge of the firing squad
who shot private Stevenson and were published after the war.
It was a terrible scene.
Being that I knew him made it worse for me.
The 10 men were selected for the firing squad from a few details left out of the
line.
Okay.
They were nervous wrecks themselves and two of them had not the nerve to fire.
Of course they were tried by court marshal,
but they were found to be medically unfit.
Their nerves had gone.
The last words the lad said were,
what will my mother say?
Yeah,
you have one more.
And this was an interesting
writing.
There was a private name,
private Frederick Butcher and the report that comes out was actually published
in a newspaper years after the execution.
But,
and,
and he calls the private Frederick butchery calls him Jim,
but this eye witness to his execution wrote about it in a paper.
Okay,
I shall call him Jim.
He had been out three years.
He'd been wounded,
but he was wounded at a time when wounded were cared for in France and we're
back in the line in six weeks.
There was nothing about GM which attracted special attention.
He was the average happy go lucky sorta lad who did the day's work on an average
in the average way war had become normal to him and he had settled down to that
fatalism which characterizes so many of our men.
When they said,
if it is to be,
it will and if it ain't,
it won't.
As if he had suddenly been hit in the mind,
he stood stock still to still one night and point blank refused to go over with
a raiding party.
In an instant,
he became a marked man.
His comrades could not quite determine whether it was bravery or idiocy.
Perhaps some string had snapped some something somewhere had gone wrong,
but Jim just refused.
He was exceedingly nervous.
But such a breach of discipline was in itself sufficient to account for that.
By the time he stood on the mat before the court,
he had partly regained his normal composure,
but the seriousness of the situation that had washed away the color from his
face and there was a dull med and look in his blue eyes.
Yeah,
his record saved him.
It was good.
And his judges tempered judgment with mercy and consideration.
He had been many platoon he had,
he had had many platoon commanders,
many captains and all and with all he had done his bit.
The court gave him a chance.
He made no excuse whatsoever,
but when question,
but when asked the question,
he promised that it would not occur again.
A week later it did occur again and the next court sentenced him to death.
Blind folded with his hands tied behind him.
He was to be shot at dawn the following day.
Okay.
From the death century,
Jim learned the names of the officer and men who were to send him a west next
morning.
Okay.
They were all his friends,
two or three officers who had known him for years,
went into the deaf hut and said goodbye.
Somehow none of them could quite catalog Jim as a coward,
okay?
Terrible things happen in war,
but nothing perhaps is more terrible than to send one of your own out of life
when you,
you're not quite sure whether he is a coward or a martyr.
The world will never know the real truth.
There was no psychologists there to give an opinion.
Even if there had been,
it might not have altered the course of events.
Discipline even then might have one,
an unfair victory over
in the mechanism of Gin Jim's mentality,
a cog slipped and the wheels revolved irregularly
from what the CEO and Jim's pals told me.
I am fully persuaded that Jim died as a martyr to discipline.
Jim was blind.
Folded,
okay?
His hands were bound together behind him as he stood there,
calm and steady as a rock.
The orders were given.
Okay,
goodbye,
sir.
Goodbye boys.
He said,
just as if you were off on a 10 day furlough,
okay.
There was no reply.
The subaltern was choked with emotion and the firing squad as a part rent as he
dared not reply.
Okay.
The sharp crack of a volley smothered sighs of relief from the squad.
Yeah.
And all was over
all save lane,
been him beneath the soil of France
and there where Jim lives there shall remain forever.
A little bit
of England.
Well,
as I said,
this is a
awful thing and I'm sorry to have to bring it up and I'm sorry to have to talk
about it.
I'm sorry that that we human beings are capable of this
and at the same time
it's good to know what we are capable of so that we can prevent it.
And eventually in 2006
after way too long and after a lot of effort and hard work by a lot of
compassionate people,
the British government admitted that it was wrong.
And the story of that effort is retraced.
In the first book I read from,
he was no coward and it resulted in the pardon.
Okay.
Of Harry far and of 306 of the other soldiers
who were executed
who were shot at dawn for the crime of having
psychological breakdown under the immense mental and physical trauma of World
War One.
And in 2006 Harry Fars daughter dirty,
who we started this story off with,
girdy was presented
with a letter from the secretary of Defense,
Desmond Brown,
which included the official pardon for Harry far and it reads this document
records that private Harry far of the First Battalion of the West Yorkshire
Regiment who is executed for cowardice on 18 October,
1916 is pardoned under section 359 of the Armed Forces Act of 2006
the pardon stands as recognition that he was one of many victims of the first
world war.
And that execution was not a fate he deserved.
Okay?
Sign Dez Brown,
secretary of State
for defense.
And so he was pardoned.
And I would say that private Harry far,
we,
we beg your pardon.
And
I would say,
let us learn something from this.
Something about leadership and something about our behavior as human beings.
Our nature as human beings.
Let us learn something
from the fate of Harry farm.
And that is that we as human beings are not infallible.
We are not perfect and we will fall short of the ideals that we aspire to will
fall short of those.
And we may not always be as bold and we may not always be as heroic and we may
not always be as brave as we want,
but while we may fall short on those traits,
yeah,
let us never fall short
in compassion,
in sympathy
and an understanding
and let us,
when we look to others,
let us remember and let us know that our judgment is as imperfect as we are.
I remember
that it is us who
in the words of Wilford Owens,
we are the ones that dealt them war and madness.
And so let us also be the ones who deal them mercy.
Yeah.
Find forgiveness.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles,
kind of a rough one.
Yeah,
odd.
It's like an odd feeling,
right?
Just that even though that final part of that last book,
how you know,
you got to essentially kill or witness both your friend.
And even until that,
it's not like you guys are friends,
he'd be trays,
you know,
and you're mad at them and then you kill them.
It's not that.
It's like,
yeah,
some other thing kind of happened.
Meanwhile you're still friends and then you got to be a part of in whatever way,
like right in front of his face too.
Yeah.
Like him dying and the kind of where you're literally saying bye.
Hey by,
and then next one dead.
And Yeah,
just kind of,
you know,
when you think he read these books,
you have this picture in your mind,
you know,
and it's just,
it's so off putting just all the different facets that just come to play with
the scenario like that.
And there,
there's,
I mean obviously there's a,
there's a huge dichotomy in this is the huge dichotomy in this is that there's
all these millions of brave soldiers that went,
that went over the top and they were killed.
And so how can you have any sympathy for the people that are like,
no,
I can't do it.
Yeah.
And,
and the answer is you've got to recognize that different people are different.
and you know,
it's interesting that that last guy calls him a Marger and the perspective that
even someone that stood by him and someone that fought and took the same risks
and could have been killed himself and happened to live,
he recognizes like,
hey,
yeah,
this,
this happens.
And you know,
there's one part that kind of,
when you went to hear about this,
the one guy gets rolled up or gets caught by some guy that's patrolling around
the rear looking for deserters.
It's like when I hear about that guy,
I can picture that guy can picture that guy.
He's in the rear saying,
Oh,
you need a more brief,
get,
get up to the front.
You can picture that guy.
And that,
that kind of makes me angry because you got somebody that's in the rear policing
up,
people sending them to the front.
Why don't you up on the front,
get up there yourself.
But yeah,
so there's a dichotomy to it in that you know,
you,
I mean obviously you uphold and have the utmost respect for the bravery of the
people at step up and they're on,
put them on the,
I put them on the highest pedestal and then you've got these people that
contradict that,
that I think that the line gets drawn in the fact that these guys lose control.
They can't do it.
They can't do it anymore.
They mentally can't take it.
And again,
you know,
this is the same thing that Dick Winters said.
The same thing that Hackworth said that the guys reach a limit and they're done.
And only people that have been an extensive combat recognize that the people
reach a point.
And there's,
there's that whole section in band of brothers where they,
some of those guys that are total studs,
they,
they can't go anymore.
They break down and Dick winters was like,
okay,
we as a leader,
this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to do my best to take care of them if they,
if we can get them recovered,
cool.
If not respect,
if not,
hey,
it's okay.
You did what you could.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a,
it's a strange dichotomy and you can't help but try to imagine not necessarily
the specific scenario,
but like what does,
what does it,
how does it feel to literally like not be able to do something,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Well there's,
there's a lot of shame for these guys that came home and there were ashamed that
they weren't wounded,
they weren't physically wounded and,
and,
and the government treated them very badly.
In many cases they'll go,
oh,
you're cowards.
And so it's awful.
It's absolutely awful.
So I hate World War One.
I Hate World War One.
And that's an shoot.
That's the thing too.
It's not like,
you know,
they're taking a spin class and they quit halfway through because they were too
tired or something like that.
This is no echo.
You are correct.
And not the spin classes,
world war one,
by the way,
like super treacherous.
Super.
Yeah.
And then you're like,
Oh yeah,
what?
You're,
you don't have the guts or you don't,
you're not brave enough for this.
And then people,
people back in back in the safety of call,
call and judgment on,
on guys that,
and that's the other thing is these guys,
almost every one of those guys,
they had fought for some certain amount of time.
They just have it for six months,
12 a year,
two years,
whatever.
They had fought and fought and they broke years.
So yeah,
man,
it's awful.
It's awful.
Um,
but you know,
I think it's something that if we can keep in perspective,
because there's so much judging.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
People judge each other all the time.
It's like,
you know what?
Take a wrap off your judgment that that was,
that was my,
that was sort of what I was thinking through the whole time.
I was thinking about how often am I judging someone?
You know,
it's like,
well,
yeah,
you don't get to judge.
You look at the judge,
you just,
you just do,
you worry about you and hey,
instead of trying to judge,
why don't you try and help someone?
There's a novel idea.
Instead of placing judgment on someone that's having a hard time with something,
why don't you try and help them?
Why don't you try and figure out how you can support them?
Why don't you figure out what they need?
They just think of anyone had that attitude on person would have stepped up and
said,
hey look,
I know this guy.
He was a good guy.
Let me try and get him back in the game.
Let me try and figure out what's wrong instead of everyone jumping on board the
Judgment Bandwagon.
Yeah.
It kind of seems like it's that feeling of like,
I'm over here,
you're over there like,
hey,
I don't need that kind of help,
so why should you kind of thing,
don't judge,
don't judge.
All right.
Instead of judging help.
How's that?
That's your,
that's my motto.
Instead of placing judgment,
how would you help someone out support somebody's support.
I like what you just did there.
Speaking of which,
how about let's go into some support,
you know,
support yourself before you go to that.
That opening poem by Wilfred Owen is freaking legit.
Yeah.
Freaking legit.
And it's,
I should read it again.
I should have read it at the end or something,
but go back and listen to it because it's,
it's,
it's uh,
it's incredible tome from a guy that went through all that.
He went into the psychological war.
If it was called that he went through the,
what would be,
would have been called a psychological ward at the time.
And then he went back to the front and then he was awarded for valor and then he
got killed and he wrote that powerful,
powerful poem.
It's freaking awesome.
So I had to throw that out there.
Go back and listen to it.
Yeah,
totally.
Well support if you will,
back to support,
back to sport.
All right.
Here are some outstanding ways to support yourself and it's podcast if you're
down for that first origin.
Okay.
Origin is our company.
I feel like it's everybody's company.
We are,
well,
let's say maybe not,
we can't include our international listeners on that.
We can definitely include our American business.
If you're an American listener,
if you're hearing the good old us of a origin is our company and you're
including that for sure.
But I have been,
you know,
I've been hearing things that even people in the UK,
they're waiting,
they're open arms when,
when are we getting milk in the UK,
when you know they're asking these questions.
So open arms,
boom.
I think that it is,
it is.
Or soon to become everyone's company checks.
Just the kind of company it is.
Let's face it.
Just cause everything's made in America,
which I'll go into,
doesn't mean you have to be American to be true.
It could be down for just good treatment of the workers know they're not in a
sweatshop.
No.
They're actually note in there actually on one,
one 25 high street.
I don't know what at one 25 is,
but I dig.
I see.
Address.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I don't know,
maybe there was some sort of term,
no,
it wasn't some sort of like,
anyway,
yes.
Origin.
So what do we got at origin?
Okay.
If you're on the Jujitsu bad.
If you're on the path and you do too,
it's part of your specific situation.
Boom.
You're going to need a geek.
You're going to want a,
you don't need a g,
don't need anything.
So this is what you're going to want big time actually kind of need.
Again,
if you're going to train to denser with a g,
you're going to need a gate.
Well,
yes,
that's the show tonight.
All right,
well here you go.
So you do need to get,
you know,
you don't need to train.
No good you Jitsu,
but it is highly recommended.
In fact,
it is an affirmative.
You should train g and okay.
Yes.
So I would personally agree with that.
Geeky Nogi,
Jujitsu,
both all everything.
So therefore we can conclude we do need Ughi.
Yes.
And if you're wondering what g to get,
boom,
wonder.
No more origin.
Has Geese all made in America by the way.
But these are quality geese made from scratch,
by the way.
By origin for Jujitsu specifically anyway.
Best cookies in the world.
Oh yeah.
Kind of by far too.
Yeah.
There's not much competition out there anyway.
Or domain.com that's where you get them keys,
rash guards,
uh,
also some other stuff,
you know,
some joggers,
some sweat suits,
some shirts,
you know,
that kind of stuff.
Apparel.
Sweatsuits sweatsuits I think it's funny when you go,
what do you represent?
The full origin sweatsuit.
Max Comfort Max Comfort.
Experience it for yourself.
But yes,
all that stuff you got your cell phone wants to.
We've got supplements,
uh,
origin and we got joint warfare for your joints.
We got Krill oil,
which is for your joints and everything else.
And what else?
Discipline.
The discipline gives you a little,
we'll say a little edge edge.
The maths of Jujitsu and on the maths of life of life.
Yes,
much so.
Mental Edge,
physical edge.
You know,
vitamins,
vitamins are specific,
but we'll say for lack of a better term of vitamins for your brain or your whole
situation actually.
And then you got milk,
which is,
which is glorious.
It's a protein dessert fortified.
Here's the thing about,
okay,
so here's the thing about milk,
which I found out.
If I keep finding these things out here,
I'm not the kind of hair,
evidently I'm not the kind of person who's like doing all the research.
What are the benefits of this thing?
Apparently I would,
I thought it was that kind of person who's just started drinking it and be,
yeah,
you're looking at,
yeah.
I'm like,
cool,
I'll taste it.
Boom.
I tasted it.
It tastes like super good.
So I'm like,
okay,
I met and then you 10 you start to become in the mood for some Shaytan,
a milkshake.
Milkshake.
And so I'll be like,
yeah,
I'm kind of,
here's what I did do.
I did this a bunch of times in a row.
So I guess I do this.
I make a peanut butter jelly sandwich
and a milkshake and I put some of the peanut butter in the mall and that's the
chocolate mint one.
And that's a weird thing.
It tastes good.
Tastes really good.
Wait,
wait,
what?
What's weird?
Peanut Butter Jelly Sandwich peanut.
Which Wayne at butter and meant oh yeah.
Went together.
Now see.
And you'd think,
yeah,
sure.
That is kind of odd.
It's not odd.
Okay,
well you want to do that for much longer because we've got peanut butter milk so
he can,
you can just be cool.
Just chill and all that peanut butter in the mint and to me it's all good.
Put it all in there.
It's coming at you strong or you're just getting all up on the peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches like you're like you're nine years old.
I remember old school.
That's the way to gain weight.
Those are,
remember that?
I just remember,
oh,
what's for breakfast?
What's for lunch?
Pb and J.
Yeah,
we'll go on.
Remember the little plastic zip lock bag?
Actually we need to have Ziploc bags back in the day.
They just had like a fold over flap.
There'd be jelly smeared all over that thing.
Mom never put enough jelly on the peanut butter and Jelly Sandwich.
I'll never,
it was all,
all,
all the bids.
You want your peanut butter in there.
Why is it cheaper?
The cost,
the same thing.
I put more jelly on the sandwich.
Mom,
come on.
Where are you at?
Good.
That sweetness.
Go it.
What makes it funny is that that is 100% sure.
It's a universal,
it's universal.
What's up with the moms get taught at mom's school.
They offer,
hey me back on the jelly.
No,
you know what it was not.
Think about it when you buy it.
I mean I don't know how much peanut butter you buy at the store and Jelly,
but probably as smart.
I mean the jelly things are a little bit smaller.
Smaller and a little bit more expensive.
Yeah.
And the peanut butter thing is huge.
Well,
potentially,
I mean,
you know,
you've got some kids who should ever
crunchy,
creamy,
whatever,
but you get the peanut,
the huge peanut butter.
You got the little jelly with jellies,
more expensive.
Mom's trying to,
you know,
she's Jenny be economical,
but the whole deal went to that home depot course.
That home economics class.
Do you have home economics in high school?
Yep.
Home Economics in high school too.
It's good.
My mind a shot.
I think my little sister got kicked out of Home Mecca next.
Oh yeah,
that was funny.
Yeah,
I could see that.
You didn't get kicked,
kicked out.
Ah,
I definitely got in trouble a couple of times in home economics,
but I,
but I didn't get kicked out by my little sister.
Got kicked out for what?
Putting the butter knife in the toaster or something.
I forget what she did.
I'll,
I'll research that and get back with you.
She was a,
she's a character,
so you know that home economics was a little tough on her.
She's a character.
For some reason that doesn't surprise me,
but you know,
I know other members of your family check Moke you back.
All right.
Yeah.
Hey,
I sold milk protein added protein.
Here's the thing.
Okay.
So back to my point.
My point was I don't do all the research,
you know,
so I started just pounding milk.
He hit on the mold,
train hardcore and meanwhile I'm discovering all these new things
I knew about the probiotics.
Um,
but now it's like,
I find out it's Kido friendly.
It's,
I mean,
unless you mix it with milk,
because I mix it with milk.
I should make that clear.
I mix it with milk.
Yeah.
But you go like,
what?
What,
like what's each you go?
Like I said,
if you mix it without milk,
if you mix it with water then you're talking ham sandwich level of goodness.
Yeah.
But there's like,
it's like,
it's good.
Like
that's true.
That's true.
I haven't tried it actually.
I will try it.
And here's the thing too,
and this is,
if you Jocko don't know that much about this part,
it won't surprise me.
There are so many milk like sub variance variance.
We need lactose free.
All kinds.
There's like a lot.
Yeah,
there's a lot of options for that.
And when you're talking Kido,
that's a whole,
you know,
that's a,
that's a whole like dietary plan,
you know.
So there are a lot of options.
So nonetheless,
regardless of what you mix it with,
have you mixed it with any other kind of milk,
milk,
almond milk,
almond milk's not kido friendly.
Like I said,
I don't know,
well,
I'm not unnecessarily go coconut milk.
You can go coconut milk and you could get there and actually you've got to get
the real coconut milk.
You can get that fake coconut,
you can get hurt.
You can't get the,
the,
the milk.
That's the coconut milk that they're trying to sell you as like a health thing.
Well not,
yeah,
not Co.
And they're dumping a bunch of sugar and they're on this side.
Wait,
are you talking about coconut water?
Because there's coconut water.
No,
I've told him not talking about,
I'm talking about coconut milk
Bra in Hawaii.
We learned all about that at school.
The difference,
we know coconut milk and coconut water.
Oh Man.
All right,
well there you go.
You are right though.
You were right about the book in the milk.
If you get the,
you know,
the unsweetened one,
the real kind.
Yeah.
They're real straight coconut men.
That's Quito,
you're saying?
Yes.
Okay.
So that's the one I mixed it with.
It's kind of like done hidden billion grams of fat.
So it's a 98 grams of fat and they can of coconut milk,
but as far as Quito goes,
that's dope.
Yeah.
But we're talking about the milk itself though.
The mall is the powder.
Yeah.
So that's Kido.
So whatever you mix it with,
that's going to be,
you know,
in extreme ownership situation,
if you want to stick with the Kido kids,
stick with the cute him.
MOCA is part of that,
that deal check.
Then the last good,
good,
clean protein,
probiotics,
all these things and it tastes good.
And here's the thing,
it's not like,
oh yeah,
all these benefits and then by the way it tastes good.
It's not that to me it tastes good.
Oh,
and by the way,
it has all this good.
So now with me on the thing about the importance of things tasting good or I
should say the importance of things.
Tasting questions.
Yeah,
you're with me.
That that is,
that is probably possibly the most important thing.
If you're going to bring something into your game like fully,
you know,
if this is going to become part of your life,
if it doesn't taste good,
it's not going to come part of your life.
And if,
and if you bring something to it that's part of your life that tastes like crap,
like how long are you going to sustain that for and why?
When you can have something that you don't,
you don't have to have that beef anymore.
I can go.
Right.
Yeah,
and that's the whole reason I like it.
Like I said,
peanut butter jelly sandwich with the all right,
and I'll put a little bit of peanut butter in it.
Like I said,
and I'm like,
it is literally like a dessert.
I'm like pounding it on the thing.
It's really good.
No,
the last,
yeah.
Well very good origin main.com that's where you get these outstanding things.
Also,
Jujitsu immersion camp,
back to Jujitsu and origin in and of itself in a,
of course a lot of it.
Yes.
There's also Jujitsu there.
Strangely enough.
I know.
Best Way to learn Jujitsu.
Most of the A,
I'm sure there are exceptions,
but if you immerse yourself in any activity,
that's a very,
very effective in good way to learn.
And there's any Jujitsu immersion camp.
Yup.
August 26 through September 2nd this year.
But that's coming up.
Yeah.
A bunch of us are going gluing some people that have never trained before.
Oh wait.
Okay.
So did we find out whether or not it's sold out cause we're all talking and just
check the website and it's not sold out.
Okay.
So it's not sold out.
I don't,
it might be close,
but go and sign up now.
Yeah.
And that way you can go and then,
yeah.
Well that's the best way to find out if it's sold out,
called sign up.
If it says cool,
you're signed up,
you're solid.
That means nurses days.
Bring a tent.
Echo Lake Tent.
Get some as I say,
but yeah,
I got a lake.
Tent,
mosquitoes,
mosquitoes.
Is there mosquitoes everywhere?
I guess main.
It's the state bird up there because we go
through my jeans at night.
Can you imagine a mosquito?
This is so psycho.
It just like comes up jeans.
No factor,
right through those without Stinger.
Yeah,
the needle.
Yeah.
That's the main was,
yeah,
that's weird.
On quiet.
There's mosquitoes for sure.
They're not,
they're legit mosquitoes,
but I don't think maybe if you go in the mountains or something like that,
well they only have to bite through that lightweight hoodies.
They don't have to be so hardcore.
No,
that's true.
Nonetheless,
immersion camp,
real good on a lot of people going,
man.
A lot of people,
legitimate people going,
beginners,
advanced everywhere.
Dean [inaudible] Dean list.
That's an advanced guy,
obviously advanced on to say the least.
Nonetheless,
that's going to be for a second.
Can we get it all?
So Jocko has a store.
It was called Jocko store.com so [inaudible] dot com this is where you can get
shirts if you want to represent and to represent that,
that the path that we're all on,
if you will.
Discipline equals freedom.
Is the path.
Really?
Yes.
Well,
it's like fried.
It's like the path is discipline actually.
I don't know if that's right.
Discipline equals freedom is the sort of like the roadmap,
the past.
Yeah,
the path,
the path.
That path is actually doing it.
This one is the path and then freedom is,
it's like this dude,
the destination where you're continually trying to go.
Yeah,
but you're the,
you're just existing in this fabric freedom because of the discipline.
True.
However you want to assert it.
If you want to represent good chocolate,
store.com you can get shirts,
rash guards,
hoodies,
hats and beanies and whatnot.
Shirts.
Did you say t shirts?
Tee shirts on there.
Trucker hats,
tank tops.
Even just getting warm man.
Wait,
it's been warm male tank tops.
Male tank.
Oh
there you go.
Oh that's good.
Do it.
But yeah man,
if you want a representative are they,
are they uh,
cause you know I'm not super uh,
fashion aware.
Yes.
I think our tank tops out in or out of style because tank tops or the reason
that I ask this is because first of all I wear the same clothes forever.
Yes.
I don't wear them until they're completely destroyed.
Well I had,
when I met my wife I had a bunch of tank tops that was sort of like my go to,
I just warm all the time cause it's hot.
Right.
Well I didn't wear them all the time but anytime the temperature,
anytime in the summertime,
anytime I've walked past it one more time.
Functional.
And then one day when my wife,
cause they were all old and ratty and they had Guinness stains on them and they
were just all jacked up.
I didn't care because whatever.
And my wife through every single one of them away.
Yeah.
Every single one of what?
Like just,
and the thing is in her mind it wasn't spiteful.
Yeah.
She was actually like super stoked.
Like,
oh yeah,
I know.
Yeah.
You know how those old I the uh,
the dirty shirts,
I threw them away.
So you just have clean shirts now you're welcome.
You know,
she's coming at me with your welcome,
Eh,
and meanwhile these were all like my favorite.
They were all super,
you know,
wear a shirt that's like 14 years old.
It's super comfy.
Yeah.
I know.
The idea that you're the comfort dude come on a tee shirt that's 20 years old.
It's more comfortable than a teacher that's brand new.
Correct.
Yes.
Okay.
So I had a whole series of tank tops like that.
All super comfortable.
My wife threw them all away.
I've been complaining.
The one thing is my wife complains about me is that when something happens like
this,
I hold it against her forever.
I still bring it up.
Like,
you know it's been hot lately.
Yes.
You know them all like,
oh,
she's like,
I can't believe how hot it is.
I mean,
I could have a nice fat,
some tank tops,
but
so,
okay.
Tank tops,
I need to go back in the game with a tank tops coming at you to,
to answer your question,
our tank tops,
what would you say in fashion?
Yeah,
because when I think tank tops,
I also think like eighties dude,
right?
Which is pretty much what I was
and probably still am,
but I'm just throwing a question out there to make sure I'm not out aligned with
the,
you know what though?
I think tank tops,
remember them pants that,
I forget what they're called,
but like the bodybuilders were,
those pants are kind of like an elastic waist were printed.
All wacky.
Like I don't know if that's the equivalent right now,
may,
I don't know if we were to roll out like that,
but
those things were functional.
I mean if the pants were like fuck,
but they were super not functional,
I mean functional for what?
What I want.
Those pants were called,
what do you think they were actually called?
I think that a name?
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't know what they're called.
I know,
and this is a different type of pants,
but you'll remember the MC hammer pants.
Yeah.
Those are slightly different for it.
Similar,
but yet the bodybuilding ones wouldn't imprint on them.
Yeah,
they're kind of whack.
They're kind of low risk.
Yeah.
Balloony but tight at the ankles.
I actually never had a pair of those.
Thank God.
I could see that.
That's the kind of thing where it's like a picture of that surfaces on the
Internet and you're like,
damn yeah,
that's all it's,
it's retro actually.
You know,
they bring it up so maybe it's coming back.
Maybe the back maybe.
All right.
Tank tops a live there in nail.
They'll never go out because
they're functional.
They're like cooler.
They're not as hot.
Yes.
So we're down with them.
I agree.
So boom,
we got that.
Get on it.
If you want to represent chocolate store.com sweet.
Do it.
Women's stuff on there too,
by the way,
actually,
I'm said that already,
but can't overstate it.
Something that to me,
buddy,
you actually can't overstate
for now.
That's sort of like part of your thing,
I guess like tank tops and overstating stuff.
There you go.
What about subscriber?
How about subscribe about that?
Let's let you,
we'll shift gears here.
Great Way to support is just simply to subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already,
and then lever of you so I can read your phone.
He Review,
Oh,
you're smart and intellectual review,
but you might want to leave a funny one.
And also the warrior could podcast.
Yes.
Good one.
Regardless of who you are,
if you're,
if you have any relationship to kids on any,
even send my continual basis where it get past podcasts,
very beneficial,
I press record and listen to it and I personally bring the lessons home.
I do too.
I'm digging on the and we're getting great feedback.
Yeah.
People are digging it.
Yeah,
I'm digging it.
You're digging it.
Good one for teachers too.
Yeah.
Uh,
which is,
you know,
obviously that fits the category of having strong relationships with kids.
Also Youtube,
uh,
you can get your warrior kid videos on Youtube and you can get the Jocko podcast
videos on youtube and is actually been stepping up his game big time at my
active semi-active.
I guess that's a step up that you said I active on and he makes not only the
videos of this podcast,
but he also makes a enhanced ones with lots of graphics.
You need to let them know sometimes.
Maybe he's brushing up against going to crazy.
Right.
It's,
we've been talking about it.
Yeah.
If,
if too many things explode.
I mean,
let's face it,
there's a lot of movies out there,
one of those movies.
Uh,
no,
but what's like the boost?
What's the most,
the best one?
Commando.
Okay.
So they're commando has just,
no,
you've got to go with a more modern one where there's more CGI and just
everything's blown up.
Dang.
I watched one of the other day with my nine year old daughter,
everything blew up.
Everything was on fire,
everything.
It was starting to seem like it was one of your videos.
There you go.
You got that new tool.
The only,
the only video that's I think is truly brushed up against that you've made,
I don't think it across the line,
but the warpath video you were brushing up against everything that I did.
Exploded.
Turn to dust.
It caught on fire.
You were on the warpath mediocre.
It was thematic and it happened to be Christmas time at the time for the
original one cake.
No bread still on.
There's that.
Nonetheless you can.
Those are all on youtube.
Yes.
Videos also when we're working out just got rings.
I told you that they just came in.
Boom.
Really Nice ones too.
You can't do muscle ups though.
Cause your arm.
Not right now.
No,
but here's the thing.
But I never got into muscle ups.
That's wrong.
So I've attempted muscle ups and I've seen that there's a technique to muscle
ups like if certainly,
yeah.
So I've never had the pleasure of doing a muscle up ever.
Never done a Muslim rings bar.
Nothing.
So when my arm heals fully capable,
I'm doing muscle up.
That's my whole,
I'm going to be one of things also a pistol squat.
Okay.
So I've done pistol squats before.
It really hard,
really clunky,
really ugly even.
But then that call you out on that one day,
like while we're doing the podcast,
like after the podcast I was like,
Ooh,
pistol.
And then I was like,
well let's get [inaudible] or you're not as flexible are you?
No,
no,
no.
I am.
I remember you were like,
you were like,
Dang it.
Mirror flexible in my knees and my ankle.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We got a lot of room to move around.
So
side splittingly funny.
Anyway,
very flexible.
I'm gonna do pistol squats and muscle ups watch and be really good at it.
Nonetheless.
My point is,
I got my rings anyway.
My action point is we're talking about on it.
So you go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko this is where I have been getting
outstanding work out gear that deviates from my normal dumbbells,
you know,
whatever.
So that's how I got turned on to kettle bells.
All this good stuff.
They have some good stuff.
The bag,
you know,
like the,
I don't think it's a Bulgarian bag.
You know what a bulk area in by himself guarantee back.
And I have the big sand bag thing from it.
Okay.
So how big is your sandbag?
Bigger than yours?
Oh No,
the one,
there's just one size I think from on it.
Okay.
Well yeah,
but then you can you fill it up.
Okay.
How much does your shirt,
I have no idea.
No,
no,
no.
Go ahead with,
tell me just so I can fill up more.
Put an extra pound in there.
Cool.
But I've been doing that.
Um,
the farmer's scary thing been to,
I mean,
my arm can't sustain too much weight,
but bro,
it's solid.
It's a solid,
I went around the block through the day with my war.
No sixes,
two of them,
one in each hand.
And like I just like,
okay.
You know,
it's,
it's definitely challenging as it takes and I have to set them down a couple
times during that lap.
But what I noticed was the next day,
like my entire,
my entire like traps,
neck,
shoulders,
everything and forums were all sore.
Yeah.
So I knew I had that in the routine.
I was doing it pretty regular cause I like to see how far I can get each time.
But anyways it's,
yeah,
it's really good just for your body.
How far is your block?
I don't know.
More than
well block is about what?
You can't cause a box around this.
I'm thinking like city blocks downtown San Diego specifically.
It's different with different nonetheless.
Anyway,
[inaudible] dot com slash chocolate really cool stuff on there.
Cool Info as well.
Don't you can get stuck on that website because it's a lot of cool stuff on
there.
Also psychological warfare,
it's an album with tracks a lot of people ask for on the alarm system.
This is of an alarm that you can put in your phone and it's me talking about
times that you might want to slack off.
This will not allow any slack,
psychological warfare.
It's on iTunes,
Google play,
et cetera.
Check.
That was pretty concise and effective cause that that is what it is.
Also Jocko white tea.
Yeah,
I got the tea.
I'm into the cans,
not into the Bruins.
Jp,
I think JP might have a problem
tape.
He's all about it actually.
Okay.
So let me ask you this.
It has a little bit of caffeine and what's good is that JP,
JP,
my brother that boy can drink some dang energy drinks like crazy.
Like,
like where I should have as a friend been like,
hey JP talked to you,
send you to Rehab,
we need to get you off these things.
And it,
cause he would pound that stuff.
You know,
cause he's going hard man.
He's,
he's,
you know,
jps getting after it.
And so it's like,
oh,
okay cool.
I'll just drink energy drinks.
And also now he's on,
he's drinking Jocko white tea and uh,
so that's a real positive.
It's a good replacement for that crap.
He's just pounding them.
Yeah.
I mean he's told me like a crack head,
like,
yeah,
I just got another two cases.
By the way,
can you give it to little kid?
Like,
but none babies.
There's caffeine in it,
bro.
Yeah.
That's what I can give it to little kids.
Cause my son grabs what's the dead lift
lift?
The trying a little kid nonetheless.
Yes.
Very good.
Ooh.
Another thing that happens to taste really,
really good from Jocko chocolates into the little tasting.
Good thing nonetheless.
Decoy really go down organic certified.
By the way we get done with it.
You don't right now it's on Amazon and we're gonna expand that.
We got it in Canada.
It's on Jocko store too,
by the way.
I want to say Australia,
getting some chocolate tea in Australia.
We're going to go England.
So anyways,
well the store ships everywhere.
I looked,
I are the shipping from the store.
I hate when people,
I hate when people say like,
Ooh man,
what's up with your shipping?
Yeah,
I know I don't.
I'd rather you just don't buy it.
You know you are bike,
whatever.
Wait till we get it to your country.
Yeah,
we'll have it in your country.
We got in Canada,
we got it in England and we got an Australia.
Yeah,
Jocko white tea.
Well,
here's the thing that she store can get challenging because we're paying what
they're kind of charging us for the,
it's like a whole thing.
Then we're working on just slowly and slowly shipping more and plus the,
the,
the bigger we get,
we get the economy of scales.
Yes.
And so that's can make stuff cheaper too.
So I appreciate that supports from why we're on our way because one day you're
gonna be able to buy Jocko white tea.
Everywhere you go.
It might just be coming out of your drinking fountain to,
he's like,
oh yeah,
everyone's getting stronger.
Uh,
Yup.
I wrote some books.
One of them is called the way of the warrior kid.
One of them is a followup of that book series called way of the warrior kid
marks mission.
Those books will help your kid,
I promise.
How's that?
Yeah.
Should I do that?
I think I should.
I think I came that yes,
I've got,
I've not had anyone say,
hey,
my kid read that book and didn't like it and has now said that they want to get
weaker.
That is not happening.
This does not help.
Yeah.
So where the word kid books,
get them for whoever,
whenever kid,
you know,
whatever family getting free library get from whoever it's,
it's,
it's like,
it's like a good way to help man.
It's a good way to help.
Also got a book called discipline equals freedom field man.
So someone who just wrote on Twitter that that's the best book they've ever
read.
I have no frame of reference.
Might be the only book he ever read.
But I will say this,
the field manual,
if you crack that thing open and you take a little look,
it'll,
it'll reset your,
your,
your compass a little bit.
Really will,
it resets my,
I wrote the book and I still get my compass reset when I look at it.
So it's a good book too,
to get for people that are sort of like,
maybe they're a little bit there,
there's somewhere,
right?
Yeah.
They're not really going in the right direction or they're not going the right
direction.
As,
as hard as they should be.
Both.
Yeah.
It doesn't matter.
You're someone that's like completely off the path,
like this slippery slope.
You're in the,
in the,
was that place you called one time?
Like the weeds?
Yeah,
no,
no.
It was from a movie that you saw,
which is a lot of movies,
some place of misery,
swamps and feel sadness there in the swamp.
Maybe some of the sauces or get them to book,
but you get someone that's like not in the swamp,
but that's actually on the path.
They want to get further on the path,
get them that book right there.
I really like how you use swamped with sadness.
It makes me feel very easy.
References Vau so that's discipline equals freedom.
The field manual.
It's not a normal book.
No,
it's not a normal book.
Extreme ownership.
That's the first book I wrote with my brother Leif Babin and that book is about
leadership.
It's about the combat leadership principles we learned on the battlefield and
how you can apply them to everything that you do.
Now we've got to follow up book to that called the dichotomy of leadership.
The follow up book to that is actually chapter 12 of extreme ownership talks
about the dichotomy of leadership and that's balancing these opposing forces.
And we realized through Asheville in front,
our consulting company that the biggest problem people have is that they have a
hard time staying balanced as a leader.
So we wrote a whole book about it so that people can dial in and get granular.
And that's the dichotomy of leadership.
We're getting awesome feedback on it.
We're better writers now than we order then.
I mean seriously,
it's been three years I've been reading and writing up nonstop and so we're
better.
And so yeah,
that's that.
That comes out September 25th if you want the first dish,
you gots to order it now.
Someone said that they're ordering it now so that they get the first a dish so
that when they meet me and I sign it,
they're not like holding her head down in shame.
Someone else said,
hey,
oh I guess I'm a bad guy cause I gave away my first a dish of of extreme
ownership.
You're not a bad guy.
He just made a mistake.
Get somebody else.
The third edition,
the fifth,
the dish.
You don't care about that.
There's only one a desk.
You only get one crack at the title or they're very,
very noble.
You me copies of extreme of,
of about face.
I have,
oh,
I'm going to count them.
I don't know,
but I got a lot.
No kidding.
Always in the hunt for that first to dish,
a couple of them.
Gotcha.
So anyways,
that's that also I just mentioned echelon front.
That is our leadership and management consulting company.
It's me,
Leif Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
and also Mike Sorelli who's just on the podcast,
one 34 awesome podcast.
Awesome to talk to Mike.
Awesome.
Be working with Mike again.
And what we do is we solve problems through leadership period.
That's what we do.
Musters zero zero six in San Francisco,
California.
October 17th and 18th.
It's gonna sell out.
We're getting close.
But
um,
yeah,
register and extreme ownership.com.
Every muster we've done has sold out.
This is the second one.
Also.
This is an important one for current military law enforcement,
border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics,
every,
all your first responders out there.
We've got a one day leadership seminar in Texas,
Dallas,
Texas,
September 21st we did this because we want to do something shorter and focused
so that more people in uniform could get to it and it's a cheaper price point
than the muster.
So if you're in one of those types of organizations,
come to the roll call and it,
but it is a mustard.
It's a mini muster.
Would you say?
It's not really a mini muster.
It's a lead.
It's,
they're both leadership training,
right.
But this one is completely focused on these dynamic environments,
whereas the musters talking about it talks about a broader leadership
leadership,
a little bit broader,
not so focused.
I shouldn't say not.
So folks,
it's this one is specific to the dynamic environments and we can focus a little
bit more on it.
The challenges are we can address the challenges that those leaders have in
those dynamic environments as opposed to the muster where we address that one is
definitely the muster is more focused on business leadership.
Even though we get all types of leaders and we do get military and law
enforcement there,
it's focused on business more.
This one we focused and like,
and I just got back,
I mean it's worked with uh,
uh,
the Arizona highway patrol and just being out there,
you know,
you just,
you hear,
they,
its leadership and the better you are as a leader,
the better your team's going to be,
the more prepared you're going to be for bad situations.
And we Ashkelon Front does this,
we work with fire departments,
we work with police departments and we know that not every department can bring
us in.
So that's why we do this.
Well that's why we decided to do this roll call so people could come to it and
get the training concentrated one day.
So they were better prepared to do their jobs on the beat,
on the battlefield,
wherever they are.
All right.
And lastly we have the Overwatch Efo Overwatch,
which is where we are connecting special operations.
That's combat aviation vets with companies that need solid leaders.
You can go to,
you have overwatched.com to get in the game on that and if you want to spend
some time with us virtually
virtually in the virtual world until we see each other live at the muster in San
Francisco or we see each other live at the roll call in Texas or live at the
immersion camp in Maine.
Then you can find us on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on Instagram and of course on Dat Dat Phase I'll pull
echo is at Echo Charles and I have bat Jocko Willink and as always to those you
out there in uniform that are protecting us here and abroad.
That's a military law enforcement,
firefighters,
border patrol,
paramedics,
other first responders.
Without you,
the world falls apart so thank you for what you do and thanks to everyone for
listening.
Thanks to everyone for supporting.
I know that this podcast is not always
the most uplifting thing to listen to,
but I know it gets heavy.
I know it gets dark just like life does,
but I definitely don't want you to dwell in the darkness.
I don't dwell there,
but as I've said before,
I do think that we need to know the darkness so that we can steer our lives in
the right direction,
away from it toward the good and toward the light.
So go out there.
Don't be judgmental.
Go out there and fight against the darkness by doing what you should be doing,
what you know you should be doing by doing good,
by being good.
And of course by getting after it.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.